non-minimalists
how do i get started how do i continue
decluttering and cleaning and
i know that it will make my life happier
but how do i get started my i have three
boys
they have tons of legos and toys and
they obviously play with everything the
moment i try to get it out
so how do you tackle that
how do you teach them to minimize
their toys so ryan i think the easiest
thing to do here is if you just start by
getting rid of three boys i think the
toys go with them
well yeah maybe just try to get rid of
one of them at first
like a minimalism game but with getting
rid of children yeah that's a horrible
man
i think you and i are the only ones who
find that funny yeah you're probably
right yeah but
no so here's the thing we don't want to
yeah don't get rid of your kids the
people
we love in fact we don't want to
exacerbate or agitate the people we love
i think that
is is a common thing that happens when
couples start decluttering
but only one person is actually doing
the the decluttering
we need to get the buy-in first now
where do you get started
this is a common question why well
because the average american household
the average
western household has hundreds of
thousands of items in it
and we're overwhelmed with stuff we are
already you know michelle is exacerbated
by her stuff
and she's so overwhelmed she doesn't
even know where to start
how do i start simplifying and so we
just throw our hands up
now you and i have done a few different
things in fact we talk about this in
lessons now um where are two different
approaches mine was i got rid of one
item a day for
30 days just see if i could do it
because anyone can get rid of one thing
a day for 30 days
ultimately that turned into the 30 day
minimalism game which is what i'm going
to recommend
to michelle we have a free minimalism
game calendar on our website the
minimalists.com
game you can download that and it shows
you how many items you're getting rid of
but the way it works is one thing on the
first day
two things on the second day three
things in the third day so by the third
day you've gotten rid of
six things you're getting that momentum
and it's snowballing
it starts off really easy but by mid
month 15 things on day 15
16 day 69 is one day 16 and so forth
and so on and and i think
we've seen that work for tens of
thousands of people if you want to get a
bit more extreme ryan did a little thing
called a packing party
yeah that's uh i don't recommend that
for most people i mean i'm an extreme
person
i think maybe it's because i'm so add i
don't know man like i really need my
attention powerfully refocused yeah or
my perspective
powerfully refocused and the packing
party did that for me i mean
yeah i packed up everything i packed up
uh
everything literally and i unpacked it
as i needed it
and it was a great experiment i mean
when i was done i had you know 80 of my
stuff in boxes and
it really helped me shift my perspective
but you know the minimalism game doesn't
work
that's too easy if the packing party is
too crazy
then maybe uh you know somewhere in the
middle you start with like your powder
room or something with a packing party
yeah um but here you know i had a powder
room
[Laughter]
um i mean if you got powder in there
secondly a powder room
here's here's what i would recommend for
michelle too uh michelle you've got to
start with your family too
and i don't mean minimize your family
but you got to get them on the same page
so even before you do a packing party
before you do the men's game before you
do the one room packing party unless
it's your own personal room then maybe
you don't have to talk to your kids
about it
but you know what really stands out in
her question to me is how do i get my
kids on board and what you do
is you help them find the benefits
in simplifying so with kids you know
what kids love to do they like to do a
couple things
um it's taking me everything to not be a
smart ass right now talk about it
right exactly but there are two things
that i know kids like to do one is they
love
to help um that is what i mean i
remember when i was a kid i was always
trying to like pump gas from my dad
i was like always trying to like help my
mom clean the toilets like
and it's funny because i remember my dad
at one point he's like ryan you're gonna
hate pumping gas
just enjoy the time that you don't have
to pump the gap i'm like no but i want
to pump the gas
yeah and uh no i guess i don't hate it
but it's still it's a pain in the ass
but anyway
kids love to help so uh you know
give this as to your kids as an option
to help the other thing too
and i guess this kind of goes in line
with helping his kids love
to help others like donate uh
they they'd like to bring others
happiness so if you can help your kids
see
that those those toys that they're
giving up they're being donated to
another kid
and they're making that other kid happy
like the kid
is going to love the fact that they are
making someone else happy so kids love
to help they love to assist
and they also like to make other people
happy so find a way to help your kids
see those two things and maybe that'll
just give them a little bit of
of a spark to help you start but
michelle
it's easy to get overwhelmed it's easy
to throw your hands up in the air and be
like i can't do this it's too much
my kids are in the way and all my other
stuff is in the way like i get it but
you have to start somewhere
and uh unfortunately there's no magic
bullet answer that we're going to be
able to say right now to like
help you be like oh yeah i'm going to
declutter tomorrow and it's all going to
be done
yeah um the the thing that we're josh
and i are trying to tell you is
start small you got to start small
yeah and and what i think with the
minimalism game the reason it's going to
work so well for you and your family
is it does help you get some buy-in with
them especially if there's some sort of
outcome you're working towards so i
don't know what the reward is going to
be i don't know what your
your specific kids are into but there
could be a family reward there could be
an individual
reward as well so if you're playing this
game with your entire family
so each person gets rid of one thing on
the first day it all starts out really
easy
and second day you each get rid of two
items whoever goes the longest
wins if you all make it to the end of
the month well you've each gotten rid of
about 500 items
it's a phenomenal start one other thing
for your kids michelle
show them what they're making room for
as they're getting rid of the stuff they
no longer
play with the couple rules there like
the 90 90 rule we call it the
seasonality rule in our
minimalist rule book which i'd love to
give you a free copy of the minimalists
rule book you can find it at
theminimalists.com
rulebook and it's a free ebook anyone
can download it
for free or if you want the audiobook
version that is also available ryan and
i record an audiobook version but the
rule that stands out in there to me
is the one in ten out rule yeah because
you're if they get rid of ten things
maybe they're making room for one new
thing that's
truly going to add value to their life
so i think you'll enjoy that and i think
the rules in there
will help you set up some boundaries
that you need michelle
you